toujours du côté droit
ok
vous allez
[Musique]
parler
vraiment bien expliqué leur quotidien et
ça m'a fait changer la vision oui
clairement
ça donne pas
un petit peu mais c'est pas ce métier
que je vais faire tu fais quoi ce soit
mécanicien électricien ou psychologue
[Musique]
c'est valorisant
d'une part pour nous pour montrer le
métier en fait
des gens qui sont pas forcément au
courant de ce qu'on fait
ça permet de montrer notre savoir-faire
notre notre technicité tout ça et
également ça permet aux jeunes de
pourquoi pas de trouver une vocation ce
genre de choses on voit certains jeux
qui sont très très
attentionné enfin attentif à ce qu'on
leur dit et ça peut être intéressant à
la fois pour nous et pour eux
[Musique]
on voit bien que les réactions sont
totalement différentes avant et après
avoir participé à notre programme
notamment dans la façon de voir ce
qu'est l'institution policière et de
voir ce qu'est le policier c'est à dire
qu'on arrive à retirer le costume du
policier et voir l'homme ou la femme
qu'il y a derrière nous on se résout pas
à ce que on puisse savoir d'une jeune
génération qui grandissent dans la haine
des institutions et donc recréer du lien
entre la police et la population et le
premier la première brique pour
justement leur donner les outils du bien
vivre en société
[Musique]